hi-yah this video is an excuse for me to
use a new curling iron that I bought so
I've got false eyelashes on I'm sure you
actually already figured that out I want
to get better at putting false eyelashes
on so I've now started using my videos
as a reason to practice so if my eyes
look crazy in the next however many
videos it's because I'm just trying to
practice putting on fake eyelashes this
should be like 15 minutes to get these
guys on and it still seems like they're
not right so the title of this video is
probably something along the lines of
like X number of wedding hairstyles and
this is not specifically meant for girls
boys a few long hair and you care about
you know being a fancy wedding guest and
this could also appeal to you but truth
be told I bought this dumbass curling
iron at Target earlier today and I just
really want to try it out this seems
like the most appropriate type of video
to try it out in I'm gonna just want try
and curl my whole head witness excessive
piece of hair machinery from there I'm
gonna try a couple hairstyles that I saw
on Pinterest this is the ceramic
rotating curling iron look at that you
see that this is the word that got me
good it rotates in your hand and curls
your hair basically just like clamp it
to your hair and then it just rotates so
I can't wait for this to be the like
visual tangled mess that I know I am on
the inside
Thank You Target this is already open I
appreciate passion
also you're huge and so she said there's
also a home button this button right
here says the word home on it are you
the beauty guru version of me team is a
fast and slow switch there's something
that is home and there are some arrows
cool I'll plug you in Oh a number came
on there so I can put it up to a
temperatures whoa let me just actually
read up about this for a second got it
we're gonna try it I'm gonna separate my
hand into two halves oh here's your
first summer wedding guests love this
one I call no oh no no I'm I'm really
happy for you brush out some hair a hard
thing about my hair is that I have
extensions so some of it ends here and
the rest of it goes down here as foes
you're supposed to take this teeny tiny
little clamp down there and clamp it at
the bottom and then oh and then spin it
up whoa over to three seconds and open
clamp that did what my other curling
iron definitely does let me try it with
my shorter actual real hair any plant
okay that's decent this is really decent
it's never the phrases you ever want to
end a first date I'm gonna just keep
going with the rest of my hair I have a
lot of hair so I'm obviously not gonna
make you watch all of this happens wow
that is very convenient and nice I'm
into this I'm gonna switch the curl
though I can mix up the curl style so
I'm going to clamp it from behind whoa
okay a lot of you might be like that's
the dumbest thing the laziest thing but
like remember when they made the remote
control
also for any of you like myself that
consistently burn your hands trying to
wrap your hair around curling Beryl iron
thing this really helps that out fast
ped done just you know this is not a
sponsored video at all by any means but
I have to say that this curling iron is
awesome this is very nice it's like a
dishwasher for your hair like it just
does it for you oh and also whoa what
the [ __ ] L'Oreal I'm really really
excited and happy about this product
yours wedding hairstyle number one I
guess can everyone calm the [ __ ] down
now let's get into these Pinterest
wedding hairstyles so one of the most
popular ones I saw was this like great
scenario called the twisted crown sounds
like something that's happening in my
teeth right now I don't know it's from a
youtuber called twist me pretty I
started watching the video I'm gonna
watch this video and try and figure out
how to do this Frankie's oh okay oh and
how do you my butt is my heart
initiative what what what what what okay
we're gonna try this I'm gonna leave
some of these short pieces in front you
grab a triangle piece of hair and you
break it into two pieces you put this
front one over the back one haha
then you're supposed to pick up hair and
add them to each piece as you move along
Twitter and they just keep twisting back
your piece
stop look I'm doing it just like her
effortless easy to follow ash oh stop
touching the top oh so goddamn easy this
is my Olympics yet stop that feels good
and then I just continue twisting all
the way back and then I take a hair tie
and I hold it in place ah I drop my hair
good thing I got two hair ties to the
pro Twisted Sister what are you what's
your name Abby that is the most
witness-protection name I've ever heard
if you were actually in the witness
protection program I'm so sorry I got
one piece of thing happening next side
triangle of hair oh no it up so big
wowie Zowie look at you go ah stop okay
then we're gonna put a hair tie on the
end of this one wow this looks great now
I'm going to link them together somehow
how can I actually show you what I'm
trying to do right now oh my god what I
can see things okay so you just across
these over bobby pin them and I'm gonna
put way more bobby pins in then Twisted
Sister did your mama baby thing wouldn't
it to get there and everyone's having a
good time Wow
oh you can suck some dick out and you
said you're just going to take the
carrot eyes off of ends of your hair and
pin it where it doesn't feel secure so
you won't have to Syria
you know I think that's good see this is
it good I can't see the viewfinder from
a distance so I can't tell it seems not
evil so here's the front Oh No Pinterest
okay so this is first of ten right so
it's not gonna be the best this is like
sex oh no I think I like it
oh did you hear something what is that
noise Oh what is that
Oh what okay let's see another hairstyle
so look at a bunch of Pinterest
tutorials in which girls just sort of
fold their hair up into their other hair
and then attempt to do a full like up
herb up thing I'm just gonna flick with
it let's see what happens so I guess
what we're gonna do is like try to just
like fold this stuff into that stuff
just a little bit hold it into the braid
a little it is alright I'm just gonna
keep doing that
see what happens I'm just going to start
adding bobby pins in places where the
hair doesn't feel as secure you know
this is like the xanax for all the
insecure hairs you got basically when
you go for wedding hair you just want to
create a hairstyle that will last
through your own personal sweat and
determination when you're doing the
electric slide
okay does that sound like interesting I
can't actually tell okay here's my final
product from what I can see it doesn't
look awful I don't think it's bad well
oh no did I stumble onto something
authentically helpful okay I just looked
at my own hair in an actual mirror and
it's not bad and I feel too much
self-esteem
oh there's a mashed-potato bar where
okay so there are three wedding
hairstyles
I guess did I do an authentic hair
tutorial video while wearing fake
eyelashes they say you'll have a crisis
when you turn 30 I just did not expect
it to be like this thank you guys for
watching this video let me know which
hairstyle was your favorite if you liked
this video or be hated this video
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because I just like you know having you
guys around this is weird that this
worked Oh No and this is obviously not a
beauty channel I just had to say it I
know you knew that but if you want me to
do it any other sort of like style
beauty fashion DIY whatever kind of
videos let me know they're fun to try
they're weird to succeed at and I'm open
to having more feelings around them in
the future I don't know oh
this is how aliens do hair